ben shapiro got a big following very
loyal following great communicator okay
ceo and founder of daily wire
said the following this is a new york
post story ben shapiro gop cruising
for a bruising by sticking with trump
prominent right-wing media personality
ben shapiro called on the republican
party to ditch former president donald
trump to boost the chances of winning
elections shapiro suggested that gop
should nominate a non-trump candidate in
2024 to make it harder for democrats to
appeal to independent voters there is a
reason
democrats are eager to keep trump at the
center of the conversation half of the
independents say trump is a major
factor in their vote and they're
breaking 4-1 for the democrats if he
runs
republicans shouldn't play
shouldn't play that game if they do
their cruising for bruising do you agree
with him yeah so you know to some extent
i think one of the shortcomings of
donald trump was it was too much about
him
and not enough about the team that he
had assembled
in achieving the success that he did
donald trump did more for this country
in the four years that he was in office
politically meaning in making our lives
that much more prosperous than almost
any other sitting president the problem
is that there's such distaste and we've
talked about it the hatred for the
individual
had donald trump
put his party first meaning had given
more credit yeah to the republican party
yeah
i think people would be more willing to
stick to
voting republican
being meaning being against the
democratic party or against the agenda
as it is today with biden
and i do agree that it is a very savvy
and smart
uh strategy that any association
affiliation with donald trump will then
cause even someone as we talked about
the gas prices to say i'd rather pay
seven dollars than to see that guy back
in office had the republican party
taking the credit for us making us
energy independent gas at a dollar fifty
then they would vote for republican the
problem is tethered with the devil
they're not gonna vote for the
republican party i do believe there's
some credence to that yeah the most
important vote in the country is the
independent vote by far and away we
already know if you're a trump fan if
you're a maga you're going to vote that
way you already know that if you're an
obama person democrat you're going to
vote that way the independent vote is
the most important voting bloc in the
country and they're typically in the
rust belt whether it's ohio michigan
iowa you know in that area now i can
only take
um
ben shapiro at his word and if we're
gonna take ben shapiro who's a very
educated
[Music]
trump is a major factor and independents
are breaking four to one to the
democrats the alarm bell should be
sounding for the republican party if you
nominate trump
you're gonna get what's coming to you
the independents are gonna break towards
whoever it is and i would hate for it to
be freaking gavin newsom you're in
california you get it and if i i've said
this loudly proudly i would vote for
desantis in a heartbeat i'm not gonna
vote for a donald trump do you know you
know the easiest ad ever the easiest ad
ever the democrats will do
just play january 6th all throughout
september october till voting day in
november do you want more of this and
you're telling me you talk about
emotional latinos you're talking about
democrats independents they're going to
see that and be like yeah i'll pay an
extra dollar in gas i'm good on this
word to the wise listen to ben shapiro
yo all right so here's the retort to
that so you have a guy who walked into
mcdonald's in new york city last week
and had an axe in his backpack yeah and
he went and destroyed the mcdonald's and
obviously put the fear in all those
patrons to think that they were within
milliseconds of losing their life you
know what his bail was
zero he signed himself out of jail and
the mayor and the police commissioner
said
well he really wasn't intending on
hurting anybody he was just you know
destroying property now would you like
to talk to the people that were in the
mcdonald's at the time this guy was
wielding an axe and coming after them
face to face so if that's true then god
bless new york city to have that type of
political affiliation and that type of
continuation because we're going to be
the lawless nation we're right we are
teetering it's happening it and by the
way it's happening as we are watching it
happen and again it's unbelievable that
people are embracing that it's okay yeah
well may i retort to your retorts yes
okay you you're an fbi agent so you
should have done your reconnaissance did
you see what happened before that four
people were beating the [ __ ] out of him
and he stood there getting pummeled and
then he reached into his backpack after
escaping the ass whooping and got his
axe okay let's record that but i'm going
to return that what does that have to do
with donald trump people not like donald
trump because donald trump is about law
and order and gave the deference and the
respect
to law enforcement if you go back to
barack obama uh
but that still doesn't answer what ben
shapiro
but it's a carryover when i think four
or five police officers were shot and
killed in houston or dallas which is
disgusting and nobody
dallas thank you and he sat on his hands
and would not acknowledge the loss of
life in house
obama disgusting
but that sent that set
when you look back at how we
and you talk about all of these cases
and all these high-profile cases
how do we get to the point where the
general public to a large extent whether
it's true or not has such a distaste for
law enforcement it's such a lack i got a
question
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]